alright guys we're doing another ask
Dave we haven't done one of these in a
while I tweeted out this morning a link
to our TV you submitted a ton of
questions we got literally like a
hundred questions in about 20 minutes so
we picked we picked the top 20 we're
doing two videos right now here we go
Michael asked what is your opinion on
Cruz and Kasich openly colluding to
ensure a contested convention does this
kind of desperate action against the
front-runner not make voters turned off
to their message so if you don't know
what he's talking about we're taping
this I should tell you this today is
Monday so Super Tuesday is tomorrow and
what they're doing basically cruz and
kasich is they're saying to their
constituents basically vote for this guy
here this guy here because they're just
trying to stop Trump from getting to
that 1237 in the delegate count it's
pretty depressing look I'm not for any
of these guys I think you guys know that
already right I don't like pretty much
anyone running at the moment but what
they're doing it's the most sort of it's
everything that people hate about
politics like literally Kasich and Cruz
cannot win mathematically so they're
hoping hoping for the contested
convention and they're literally just
trying to coordinate how do we stop
Trump so that ultimately the party
leaders can select the nominees so it's
just sort of depressing and sadly this
is just where we're at and I have a
feeling it's not even going to work
anyway at Ellen Dean may as hey Dave
what do you think of the effects of the
migrations into European countries and
why do you think the left is pushing to
let them into the u.s. so we've talked
about this a bunch on this show and one
of the reasons I've talked about it is
because pretty much nobody in American
media is talking about it I guarantee
you saw pretty close to guarantee you
that if you turn on the big three cable
news channels today you're going to see
virtually nothing about the immigration
situation in Europe and eventually it's
going to make its way over here I would
say this I would always err on the side
of immigrants because we are a nation of
immigrants right everyone that lives in
this country your ancestors were
immigrants unless you are Native
American or your ancestors were brought
here as slaves so I would always err on
the side of helping people because
people want to come here for
life in America is still pretty good at
doing that that said we have to have an
honest debate about it how many people
can we take in how can we vet these
people properly how do we make sure that
terrorists and people that want to do
bad things are not involved in them and
things like that we're not very good at
having real honest debate here that's
why I do the show the way I do and I
hope that more people will wake up to
this so that when more people start
coming here which they probably will
will have an honest discussion about it
M salmon think says when's joe rogan
gonna be on your show Joe is incredibly
busy we've been going back and forth
we're going to make it happen there's no
doubt it's gonna happen I'm gonna go
back on his show Joe has been great to
me and actually one of the reasons that
this show has blown up the way it has is
because by going on Joe show and him
promoting me on Twitter and stuff he
helped me find the audience that I was
always looking for so yes we will get
him in here I don't know if I'm going to
do three hours with him like he does on
his show but it will happen Sean asks do
you plan to expand your repertoire
beyond just politics interviews yeah I
would love to I you know I think we do
you know everything sort of political
one way or another even if you try to
get away from politics so we did a show
on marijuana I mean that's not
necessarily political but everything
sort of comes back to politics but yeah
I want to do more on comedy I would love
to talk more about sports and science
fiction and artificial intelligence and
all kinds of stuff we're sort of stuck
we're in a weird time right now because
it's an election year and everyone's so
polarized and crazed so yeah I'm going
to try to bounce back and forth and also
do more the big idea stuff just the
philosophical tenants of freedom and
freedom speech and all that good stuff
okay lougheed said in your opinion how
should classic liberals stand up to the
regressive left to break away from
liberal being considered an insult all
right so that's a great question and it
gets to the heart of a lot of what we do
here right so first of liberal being an
insult i think is interesting i remember
i was 12 years old right when I was sort
of getting into politics 1988 Michael
Dukakis was running against george HW
bush and we were doing like a fake
election in my class and I
number George HW Bush called Dukakis a
liberal and Dukakis who was a Democrat
was like I'm no liberal another thinking
what that's so shitty like being a
liberal is good it means that you're for
helping people it means that you want
people to achieve the most they can and
all that stuff but yes liberalism and
especially classic liberalism has been
hijacked by the progressives or as we do
call here the regressive so I think the
best thing that you can do and I tweeted
out a piece from Bertrand Russell this
morning a great quote on this the best
thing you can do is be willing to debate
ideas I mean that's what you guys email
me about all the time that you're trying
to take some of these ideas into your
own life and talk to people about it and
it sucks because I all the time I get
email you guys say I'm losing friends or
this one says this about me or they say
I'm big at or racist but you know what
if you're not then don't be afraid of
what people would say about you I am
truth 96 says how much wood could a
woodchuck chuck if a woodchuck checked
his wood chucking privilege I suppose if
you checked his privilege he would be
able to chuck less than he would
otherwise unfortunately marquee star
says what's your opinion on the Bernie
or bust movement so this is the concept
that the Bernie people just simply will
not vote for Hillary ferny doesn't get
the nomination they won't vote for
Hillary or they just won't vote period
this would be a very bad move if you're
if you're a Bernie person first off if
he's got these young people excited
right now then you got it the only way
you stay excited and the stay engage is
actually by voting and guess what there
are going to be many other times and
young people will learn this over the
course of growing up there are many
times when the person that you vote for
doesn't win but you have to stay engaged
so that the the tenants of what Bernie
cares about money in politics and all
those things that those tenants will be
addressed by the next politician so you
know what you vote and then if hillary
gets in you keep applying the pressure
on her or you know what i think a lot of
the Bernie people believe it or not I'm
going to go for Trump because he's the
other guy out of the system so if it's
all about just flipping the system I
think some of them are
go there I know a lot of people don't
agree with me on that but I have a
feeling snowbanks 34 said your hoops fan
what's your team also who are your top
five not best NBA players I grew up in
Long Island and so I so the Knicks were
the home team in New York but in Long
Island for some reason we got the New
Jersey net channel so I grew up as a
nets fan they sucked for all those years
had a couple good years with with Jason
Kidd now I just like watching good
players play so as for my five favorite
players there's gonna be a little cliche
but obviously Steph he is literally
Steph Curry changing the game in front
of our eyes the guy is just unbelievable
i heard his knee is mangled as of this
morning and he's going to be out maybe
two weeks of the playoffs was which
sucks but he's changing the game which
is amazing and then the four other guys
i'm going to mention those are really
boring but the Spurs starters Tim Duncan
who the other day didn't even hit a shot
for the first time in something like 260
playoff games but watching that guy he's
like 97 years old and he's still he's
good and he plays right and just plays
with the with just passion and decency
and Tony Parker who's so old to for a
point guard what still does it and what
do we got we got Manu Ginobili also old
it I like these old guys basically
whoo-hoo still bring it all right so
let's see mike says as an aspiring stand
up from the UK I'm 19 and I want to
begin as soon as possible I just feel
poking fun at certain subjects will
result in massive push back I want to be
brave I want to be honest in my stand-up
but with everything being racist
Islamophobic sec 6 and transphobic these
days I have no idea what would be best
for me as I have been wanting to be a
comic since I was 11 it seems easy to
lose a career just by using the wrong
gender pronoun or targeting the wrong
group any advice I mean again this goes
to all the things we talked about here
first off you know the thing about
comedy is and the reason why people go
to comedians for truth is because if
you're going to hear the truth you may
as well be funny about it otherwise
you're going to get punched so yeah it's
a fine line and unfortunately because we
live in outrage outrage culture
everybody is ready to jump on you and
ban you and all that stuff and boo you
down
a comedy clubs still are a little safer
than than most places on earth for now
and my best advice would be just right
the best up you can keep getting on
stage and every time you think you're
good you'll probably realize you aren't
then you just keep going again Frederick
s are you planning on interviewing
anyone from Sweden since Sweden is at
the height of regressive pneus I'm sure
you and your audience would like to hear
what's going on so I think I've
mentioned this before probably out of
every other country out of prolly Canada
in the UK in the United States Sweden is
where we get the most mail from and it
sounds like the regressive thing is just
really taking a stronghold there give me
some recommendations of people I've
reached out to a couple people in Sweden
some public speakers and haven't had
much luck so if you've got some people
in Sweden that I should talk to yes I
would be happy to have them on and
finally Cara asks when are you selecting
the winners of the fan show so this is
remember a couple weeks ago we said that
we were going to interview that I would
interview five of you guys for ten
minutes each and make that a whole
episode we got almost 1200 responses so
if we were to interview 5 out of 12
hundred view math isn't my thing but I
know that's much less than 1% so we've
been going back and forth and we we
divvied it up amongst the team we all
went through a couple hundred of them we
have it now down to about 20 people i
think in 20 different countries we want
everyone to be from different countries
in this and we're going to select 10 so
we're doubling what we said we were
going to do and we'll shoot it in the
next couple weeks there's some
logistical stuff gotta got to work it
out with people and time zones and all
that kind of stuff anyway alright this
is part 1 of the two-part ask Dave stay
tuned for more